conseil municipal au final masculin
désir l'assemblée d'élus chargé de gérer
une ville les conseillers municipaux et
elles lisent les maires parmi eux
comme pour la galette des rois il ya
rarement du suspense c'est en général la
tête de la liste victorieuse qui tire la
fête à partir des municipales de 2014
seul le conseil municipal d'une ville de
rennes lille habitants et élus au
scrutin proportionnel avec panachage des
classes à table sont distribués en
fonction du score au public quel que
soit le régime alimentaire au delà de
1000 habitants le meunier - 10 seront
les vainqueurs en d'office la moitié des
cartons d'invitation l'autre moitié est
répartie en fonction de leurs résultats
entre les listes ayant obtenu au minimum
5% des suffrages la taille du conseil
municipal dépend du nombre d'habitants
en dessous de 100 habitants ne comptait
que 7 couvert à partir de 300 milles
prévoyaient plutôt un buffet pour 69
convives
les ébats les débats sont publics sauf
si le maire décide l'intimité du 8 une
fois tout le monde assis les
conversations de tap peuvent commencer
comme la grand-tante martin le conseil
municipal se mêle de tout ce qui
concerne votre vie comment elle va
l'avaler
à comines obligatoire au moins une fois
par trimestre une séance de conseil
municipal peut tourner au vinaigre et
quand ça devient compatible le conseil
municipal peut être dissous par décret
en conseil des ministres pas comme la
grand-tante martin malheureusement mais
effectivement les gentilles